can ai be conscious
in the same sense as i've just been
discussing it about some level of
complexity that instantiates something
independent
at least
you know probably not now right or not
in our or immediate future
can it
replicate what we think
is consciousness
very likely
i mean you already have seen the
arguments about google
right and that thing that you know that
program it's you know i don't think it's
conscious but you know it it was pretty
remarkable
it was a far more interesting dinner
conversation than i've had with even
some of my professor friends from
harvard and mit
right i mean much more
open and you know interesting i would
love to have someone like that as a
conversationalist
right so
now
where does
the transition happen for us
well again i mean
i i hate to boost his already immense
ego but not that he's listening to this
elon musk
you know basically
i didn't say stole but borrowed the
concept of neural links from science
fiction this notion that you can
interface
and
access
compute abilities we do it already i
mean wikipedia is like uh you know i
everybody's an expert if they can type
in the search terms and get a wikipedia
concept imagine
that being
instantly available to your head it's an
upgrade it's an upgrade imagine
you know something which is recording
your every moment
so that when you say where are my keys
the you know the compute in your head
said i see i saw you leave it on the
table downstairs
and it splashes that image to you sure
right that's coming
right it's coming one day
and so
we've now transferred our memory much of
our capability of the memory
to the computer let's say in some near
future um
it could record your life so
now i mean at 61 i can barely remember
some of my former dogs
you know i can remember them but i can't
remember the moment that i just had with
two of my dogs in bed this morning
petting them and
you know loving them
um
but maybe i could recreate that
so
i've now transferred memory emotions
and the
recreation of those memories and moments
to a computer
what's left
maybe just the decision processes but
then maybe we start to give the decision
processes over to the computer what
should i do today
well here's the most efficient way to
to do all the stuff that you're doing
so we become smaller and smaller and
smaller
and
what we've handed over to
an ai
is larger
and so
at what point do we decide
as
humans
that we don't need
that anymore because most of what we are
is now in the computer i would say that
we that doesn't have a soul
at least if a soul
is true
but you know maybe that's what we're
seeing in these uaps because it's a
natural extension of where we're going
unless we create laws that stop it from
happening
or there's some sort of a pogrom pogrom
or a crusade against them
it's coming
and so we will transfer ourselves over
and then unfortunately people like musk
would live forever
[Laughter]
unfortunately people would but
fortunately people like you would yes
that's that's true yeah
that's eternal into
into slave robots
but um anyway computer the danger is
control alt delete you know
that's also also a danger
i mean i'm
believe me if
elon gets something that uh or somebody
else there's other people as well just
using him as an example
um get something that allows for
memory
aids
i'll be all for it if it doesn't you
know if it doesn't like destroy my brain
in the process of upgrading you know and
then i can't upgrade further another
point i'll do i'll do it what about
intelligence upgrades
oh sure and increasing the data that you
have on board right so you're a fan of
some of the
potential of neuralink yeah but i mean
you know you've heard me probably talk
about where does creativity and insight
come from and where are we accessing
these downloads that people get
have you ever had that by the way
work is it does it feel like what i've
i'm glad you said that because it seems
like a lot of really brilliant people
end up actually backing up into an idea
that they had originally and then
figuring out the essentially the math to
it and so what are what are some of
those episodes many books written about
this and going back decades about how
people have realized that they just get
these ideas out of nowhere
i think that if we transfer ourselves to
ai
we'd lose that
yeah i'm implying that there's some
woo-woo associated with where we get
these ideas from
right i mean let's not i won't parse
words
uh you know you you could imagine into
some sort of subconscious process that
truly is just all mathematics or there's
something else going on because some of
the ideas that i've had came from
absolutely nowhere there's no way i
would have known what these things were
before i thought the idea
um so i was like okay well did somebody
give it to me or
you know i don't like to think that
there's a guardian angel or somebody out
there who really cares about me
personally um or
is there something about the way you
structure the question
that and there's a a saying if it's a a
zen or a buddhist um
concept that the perfect question is the
flip side of the perfect answer that if
you structure the question in just the
right way the answer is obvious
right
that the the the question almost
presupposes the answer
and so maybe if the physics of the
universe is some people say it's in
information physics
if the physics of the universe and it
can traverse time let's say
uh and let's say that we don't
understand enough about the universe to
say that it can't um
then
if your brain puts together
a conscious structure
that is the question
it might be
asking and
you know might be querying the universe
for the answer so it's your executive
function of who we think we truly are
that organizes the question in a way
uh in our brain that
create creates the query and it just
takes time and the right moment
for all of that to have come together to
quit the answer comes and boom it gets
downloaded
because it was already there yeah right
it's not that anybody's giving it to you
it's you're giving it to you by
creating and again it's all postulates
where does it come from
what do you think
speaking of questions what do you think
is the most important question that
humans can ask are we alone that to me
is the most important question if we're
not alone
then somebody else might have answers
to other let's say less
or more immediate existential
uh questions right that
you know what what can we do about this
what can we do about that or
you know are there other dimensions are
there you know
you know what is
you could list a thousand questions and
you know if they would be willing to
give us the answers
right and i
personally think that frankly we're not
i mean i've said this before i think
we're just a bunch of angry
um angry apes i don't think we're ready
for
uh some of the answers yet and
you know it's like you don't tell your
children certain things until they're
mature enough
and we've pretty much proven that we're
still not mature enough yet
you know it's it's interesting um
evolution as i said before doesn't care
about time dna doesn't care about time
we're sort of the first
level of civilization
that was achieved out of competition
right the tribe that was more
competitive than the other and frankly
more aggressive
um and that frankly had
you know narcissistic psychopathic
leaders
that were willing to unite
a continent
you know at the expense of blood
uh
were the ones that succeeded
but as we're seeing played out in
today's politics without getting
political
um
that's not necessarily a survival trait
for a species right it's short-term win
long-term loss long-term loss so is is
the long-term play for evolution the
creation of a certain level of
complexity that either realizes it needs
to get rid of that aggression or there
will be a collapse
a rise collapse rise until
the genetics is selected for
that
is an interesting study that was done
and i don't remember who did it and
whether it was validated or not but it
was shown that um
in women
after wars
uh that there were it was more likely
for the women's
boy children to be homosexual
interesting okay why
okay what and the end the postulate was
uh
that
they would be less aggressive
and so there's kind of an encoding
in the woman to fear
of
a problem
in terms of stress that okay we need to
lower the aggression in the males
because they're getting out of control
okay now is there an it does this happen
certainly other cases showing that the
grandmother who is starved
has a baby and if it's a woman
is epigenetically programmed to have a
child
who is more likely to gain weight
so there's this it's an epigenetic
programming event you can you can
basically
it's it you know there was a big thing
between
darwinians and lamarckians back in the
day lamarck was
a
um his idea was that a giraffe's neck
gets longer because it was reaching for
it
and somehow that gets encoded into the
dna sure
um and uh and so the uh
that was discounted for you know almost
100 or so years and yet now we find
these little subtle hints that in fact
lamarck wasn't entirely wrong
so you know and and aggression can be
moderated apparently and i don't know
that
being gay is is the right answer but
maybe there are it doesn't need to be
gay you know just less aggressive
children sure right um and or less
likely to want to fight over the females
sorry to bring all that in but it's you
know that's that's our history
um
and so you know so there's a there's
sort of a
self-regulating capacity
in human society that is at least
epigenetically
flexible
um and that we you know if we if we
think of of us having an absolutely
determined outcome that's not quite
right because our genes right
epigenetically are listening to the
context
and so there's a little bit of
flexibility built in there and that just
makes sense from a you know to build
that in from an evolutionary standpoint
is to you know you remember you're
trying to build in
solutions
and if the solution is to be a little
bit more flexible to turn the meter
up or down a little bit
i want it hard-coded
you know because hard coding of genes
takes a long time to evolve in but if
you hard code in a rheostat
then um that listens to the environment
and it mostly is going to come in
through the eggs and less likely to come
in through sperm because the eggs are
more complex
you can basically say that
the woman as a sensor
is the one that provides the egg and the
ability for the next generations at
least
most immediate generations to be
modulated a little bit
[Music]
you